[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this week I'm in Tokyo.
Isn't that cool?
OK, here's the TL;DR, your
update of the latest developer
news from Google.
Want to know how to build
a native chat application
with Firebase and App Engine?
Here's a step-by-step
guide and sample
code for both an Android
app and an App Engine-based
back-end service.
It's all available on the
link in the description below.
In the latest episode of
the Mobile Ads Garage,
David East joins
host Andrew Broadbent
to cover Firebase
for AdMob Publishers,
including how to import
both SDKs into a project
and how to link an AdMob
app to a Firebase project
so you can take
advantage of Firebase's
free and unlimited analytics.
Game developer Rayark just
hit two million downloads
with their game "VOEZ," which
is running in production
on Google Container Engine.
Take a look at the post for
principles to their success.
Kubernetes 1.3 is ready to roll
out on Google Container Engine
and will be available to all
customers over the coming week.
The latest release
addresses many top requests,
including services
that span availability
zones, built-in support
for stateful applications,
and doubling the number of
nodes in a cluster to 2,000.
For more details including the
latest updates to Container
Engine, check out the post.
Now, this is a
really cool article
over on our Web Updates page
about what to consider when
building an infinite scroller.
Spoiler alert-- reuse
your dom elements,
and remove the ones that are
far away from the viewport.
Also, use placeholders to
account for delayed data.
Jump to the post for details,
a demo, and the code.
To build products that
work for billions of users,
you need to address a
few key challenges--
limited or intermittent
connectivity, device
compatibility, varying screen
sizes, high data costs,
and short-lived batteries.
Take a look at the post for
best practices on both web
and Android to help
you reach billions
by delivering exceptional
performance in spite
of these issues.
Game developer Balloon Island
increased revenue by about 150%
with AdMob Mediation.
To learn how, check
out the case study.
Thanks for joining me
this week in Tokyo.
And don't forget to subscribe.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]